So let's take a little bit
closer look at, rods and cones.
They have a certain similar structure.
They have this, we'll call it
an outer part, but remember, the,
the pigment epithelium is up here and
the light comes in that way, but
this is called the outer part because
it's this inverted retina thing.
All right, and this inverted part
is where you have these disc shaped
elements, that react to light, and
they react to different wavelengths
of light, we'll talk about the different
wavelengths in a minute, and those
wavelengths and those reactions set up
chemical reactions in the, in the cell.
And of course it is still a cell,
so it's got these inner elements,
these organelles and a cell nucleus, and
then what's important is it
has this synaptic body where
it changes the chemical properties at
the synapses depending on the light.
So let's take a look just at the rod for
a minute.
The rod has this chemical,
these disks made out of what's
called rhodopsin, all right?
And here, this is an electron micrograph
of what it actually looks like.
And this outer segment is made of up
these plates, rhodopsin plates, and
what happens is that the, the rhodopsin
is a chemical that when it gets hit by
photons, it splits into two chemicals, I
don't remember both of their names, but
one of them is actually
associated with vitamin A.
Remember your mother always told you
you had to eat your carrots in order
to see well?
Where does that come from?
Well, the vitamin A, in, in the carrots
is involved in the chemical
that's involved in, in,
rods being able to see light.
So I'm presuming that that's
why your mother told you that.
Just ask her, all right?
To stress the sort of chemical
nature of what's going on,
there's a slide here that
just shows the same rod, and
there's a sort of this
change in these sodium ions.
And, oh here I, I wrote it down in,
in notes that, when the rhodopsin
splits, one part's called opsin, and
the other part of this vitamin A, bit.
And, when light comes in,
this change is sometimes referred
to as bleaching the, the rods.
All right, so they, they,
they start to change more.
And that, and how bleached they
are is sort of how adapted they are.
Right?
So when they're not
bleached at all a very small amount of
light, now coming in will change it,
after you've bleached them a bit.
Now you need a different, you're now
operating at a different, light level.
In fact, there were studies that
were done that were showing that
a single photon, so those of you who
are familiar with the physics of light.
A single photon will, can make a change
in the cell that this system can detect,
which is just remarkable, right?
The ability of the system to detect
small changes of illumination.
And, you can sort of ignore
this diagram over here.
It's just showing you that it's
understood at a pretty detailed level
how the light makes a change
in the chemistry, and
that the chemistry then changes
what goes on in these synapses.
Now, we said before that each of these
photodetectors respond differentially
To wavelengths of light.
And we showed you short,
medium and long.
The one we didn't show you before
was the one that includes rhodopsin.
All right, so here's the blue or the
short pigment, the green and the red,
which we've looked at before, and
here is what the, the rod responds to.
You see the rod is relatively
broad spectrum, okay.
Which is good because it means that if
there's any of this kind of wave lengths
of light coming in at night, the rods
will be able to see them, even though
they're very, very low amount of
illumination that they're sensitive to.
We're not going to talk
more about cones and
the tristimulus theory, color theory
of color because we did that last time.
But these are the four
operating spectral
responses that each of
the photo detectors give you